l'hiver approche avec lui une nouvelle
menace sous la forme d'un cocktail
inédit de virus respiratoires covid
grippe et virus syncytial que nos
voisins américains ont déjà surnommé la
triple épidémie
et
pervers
le virus
commun mais qui parfois très dangereux
pour les jeunes enfants fait un retour
en force dans les centres pédiatriques
nord-américains après une pause
pandémique de deux ans cette année c'est
particulièrement difficile parce que les
enfants ont pas été exposés ce virus
donc ils sont plus malades et en plus de
difficultés à développer l’immunité
parce qu’on peut limiter encore donc ça
prend plus de temps et en plus de chance
de développer des complications de ce
virus la saison de la grippe elle
survient au même moment du jamais vu et
on ignore encore quel sera l'efficacité
du vaccin grippal qu'on a commencé à
administrer en plus et surtout il y a
les nouveaux souverains de micro
trois d'entre eux ont occasionné des
flambées de camp nazis et se déploie
maintenant ailleurs dans le monde
aujourd'hui il représente 17% des
nouveaux cas de covid aux États-Unis 19%
en France 4% au Québec et en moyenne
leur nombre double chaque semaine à ce
rythme on croit qu'ils vont dominer tous
les palmarès de la covid en Europe et en
Amérique d'ici les fêtes et les titres
heureusement même si c'est sous varient
sont extrêmement contagieux jusqu'ici
ils ont fait relativement peu de
dommages là où ils ont frappé on a quand
même une immunité là qui devrait quand
même nous protéger de si ce n'est de
l'infection ça va quand même assez bien
protéger de la maladie sévère et des
risques de complication la vaccination
dise les experts reste encore la
meilleure façon de se protéger
de cette potentiel très pépidémie ici
normand Grondin Radio-Canada Montréal